bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 week end tout de suite le
sommaire de ce vendredi 19 février
jean-louis oraux et patrick car basa du
groupe in et montrent un quart et 800
sont en plateau
ils nous présenteront le premier just
club de la saison qui aura lieu samedi
20 février à 19h30 au conservatoire des
arts de montigny le bretonneux et
pourquoi ne pas découvrir les lieux
culturels à cheval c'est ce que propose
l'association horse in the city dans les
parcs des châteaux de grousset et
versailles ou encore dans les domaines
de chevreuse boulogne et saint cloud et
il était question également d'évoquer
l'offre d' ateliers et stages pour les
vacances d'hiver proposés par la ville
de trappes à destination des enfants et
adolescents mais notre invité à lire ab
adjoint au maire à la jeunesse et aux
sports de la ville de trappes a eu un
empêchement de dernière minute
nous commençons donc cette émission en
musique avec vous patrick car basa et
jean-louis hoarau merci tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors patrick arz basa vous êtes le
président de l'association caraïbes sont
et jean-louis euros un membre musiciens
plus précisément saxophoniste alors
caraïbes sont c'est une association qui
a été créée en 2001 restructurer en 2010
pour promouvoir le jazz et la culture
créole au travers de ses rythmes
caribéens et musiques traditionnelles
c'est sa patrie qui te feu donc
initialement en fait je suis originaire
des antilles françaises
donc j'ai baigné dans la culture
caraïbes depuis mon enfance et le
picture métropole depuis je suis à paris
donc ça ça remonte à quelques années
j'ai découvert qu'on était très absent
nous étions absents des médias pas
suffisamment présents et donc j'ai créé
cette association le projet plus afin de
monter un groupe et de représenter le
plus souvent que possible ces musiques
caraïbes
qui sont très très diverse très riche
et puis on a évolué petit à petit vers
l'idée du diaz parce qu'il y avait une
nouvelle donne avec le jazz une nouvelle
ouverture qui nous a été laissée de la
ressentent de groupe avec de nouveaux
musiciens et partie dans cette optique
voix non d'accord alors justement dans
ce musical on retrouve différents
instruments de musique des percussions
de la batterie du piano de la basse et
le vôtre votre instrument un saxophone
vous répéter une fois par semaine et ce
que vous répéter à chaque fois tous
ensemble jean louis san san boys tous
ensemble une fois par siècle on
travaille individuellement bien sûr mais
on se retrouve tous ensemble à paris
parce que bon si certains d'entre nous
sont régionaux patrick et 18 mai mme
dini montrent un mois je suis versailles
et donc voilà on est on est en soixante
dix huit essais l'origine de notre
groupe mais d'autres de nos compagnons
sont sur la banlieue sud sur la banlieue
est
donc voilà on se retrouve à parier en
travaillant ensemble alors vous
produisez plusieurs fois par an en
concert aussi bien donc sur paris que
dans les yvelines
vous avez produit un ep également en
2015 intitulé réflexions petit jeu de
mot avec le ks de caraïbes sont ceux qui
vous a valu d'ailleurs de passer
régulièrement sur les ondes de tropic fm
on vous écoute moi
la poutre
ayew
invaincus
d
alors patrick un premier ep produit
l'année dernière réflexion
d'autres suivront ils oui nous avons
déjà sur le côté quelques compositions
mais c'était notre premier set et avec
l'aide du sm a que jabot merci qui nous
ont permis d'enregistrer donc ça m'a
service de musique amplifiée avec qui
nous travaillons beaucoup et nous
préparons le deuxième avec une signature
très jazz caribéen
parce qu'il y a une culture jazz
caribéenne et je garde le lien avec mes
amis musiciens des antilles je vais voir
ce qu'ils font et je veux amener 7,7 ce
sont ce style de musique il s'est aussi
produit suite à une résidence artistique
c'est parce que juste parce que nous
avons beaucoup joué pour la mairie de
montigny et je pense que ce peut pousser
avis rendu qui nous en donner cette
possibilité
donc vous devrez également la saison des
jazz club cette année avec une première
date organisé demain soir samedi 20
février à 19h30 en compagnie du groupe
lui en courtois pam trio et ce sera au
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux c'est un lieu insolite
c'est un lieu qui s'y prêtent qui est
assez disons intimiste c'est une petite
salle avec une sono minimaliste mais les
gens du fcba savent sonorisé n'importe
quoi n'importe quelle salle ils sont ils
sont très performants très rapide très
réactif et je dois dire que alors nous
avons joué l'an dernier au mois de mai
déjà
j'ai eu l'occasion aussi de participer à
quelques autres jazz club
voilà en guest-star si vous voulez pour
avec d'autres groupes donc avec d'autres
formules et à chaque fois
non ça se passe très très bien qui plus
est le lien vers la verdad culture
graphique ou sculptures qui est présenté
dans dans la première salle
oui ça le fait très bien oui ce jazz
club se déroulera le jour de clôture de
l'exposition peinture volume présenté
par le conservatoire des arts qui
présente donc les oeuvres réalisées par
les cours de trompe l'oeil de peinture
et de céramique patrick pour vous ce
mariage artistique entre les arts
plastiques et la musique c'est
intéressant ça nourrit les pratiques
oui déjà s'inspire entre la musique et
l'art je dirais que deux lignes à ce
fond tout le temps que ce soit dans les
représentations dans les spectacles ce
soit au cinéma ou partout on peut
associer taux de formes d'art mais ce
qui est surtout intéressant c'est le
public vienne pour une curiosité
peinture dessin à la recherche de 7,2 de
ses idées de ses expériences et il a en
plus la musique c'est ça que je trouve
intéressant est des gens réalistes pour
ça donc un moment convivial sans doute
également un terrain saut de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
qui sera présent ce soir là pour
proposer un apéritif donc très
certainement au moment chaleureux pas
tricard base à jean-louis hoarau merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau
aujourd'hui est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et je rappelle donc le premier
jazz club qui ouvrira la saison cette
année aura lieu samedi 20 février dès 19
heures 30 au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux
plus d'informations sur le site de la
ville qui s'affiche à votre écran
merci merci beaucoup et à la proche des
vacances une idée insolite pour vos
sorties l'association horse in the city
vous propose de découvrir à cheval
différents lieux insolites et historique
images de camille lambert le château
dans lequel on est
elle était au 19e du toit que les
propriétaires en fait durant ses voyages
durant le voyage avait tendance à
ramener les petits souvenirs donc on
peut traverser différents continents
dans le parc on a plusieurs folie comme
cette pagode au pas au trot ou au galop
plonger dans l'histoire du parc
anglo-chinois du château de grousset
avec baptiste auclair fondateur de horse
in the city
l'association propose des promenades à
cheval dans les parcs des châteaux de
grousset et versailles ou encore dans
les domaines de chevreuse saint cloud et
boulogne
mais j'ai créé ce concept parce que
c'est vrai que sur paris j'ai trouvé
qu'il y avait pas beaucoup d'offres sur
des promenades juste pour hu à
l'occasion
voilà on est beaucoup de cavaliers à
être montés enfants adolescents et après
souvent les gens arrêtent l'équitation
et ont par la suite ont vite s'y
remettre mais ils n'ont pas envie
forçant de s'inscrire toutes les
semaines on est court mais juste
profiter sur des gens est beau temps de
promenade à l'occasion la balade peut
également être couplée à une visite
historique
l'occasion de découvrir pour les
cavaliers débutants et aguerris de
nouveaux décors comme la bibliothèque du
château de brousse est construit en 1815
et sont être inaugurée en 1957 par la
comédie française
un concept sur mesure l'idée c'est quand
même d'aller dans des lieux un peu
atypique d'aller où on n'attend pas trop
le cheval on organise des promenades
privé et du coup à partir de là en fait
toutes les tous les scénarios sont
possibles
donc ça qu'on peut on a déjà scénarisé
des promenades avec le demande en
mariage
trois heures d'activités proposées en
français et en anglais dont deux heures
de pratique à cheval et pour récompenser
l'effort
la balade se termine par un pique nique
en compagnie des moniteurs
et on poursuit notre rubrique sortie
avec la chronique de sylvie léonard
directrice d'yveline tourisme qui vous
présente ses idées d'activités pour le
week-end et voire pour les plus chanceux
les vacances nous sommes à la veille des
vacances scolaires
il y a plein d'animations dans le
département des yvelines est notamment
un festival de danse dans le sud des
yvelines à houdan
ce sont les 5 et 6 mars et là nous
allons à la découverte d'une multitude
de danse dont le jazz le classique la
danse de salon et plein d'autres dansent
encore qui font rêver et qui vous
permettent de vous évader c'est la
rencontre entre des passionnés de danse
et des amateurs qui vont échanger leurs
techniques et vous allez assister à de
merveilleux spectacle vous pourrez
également vous perfectionner puisque
c'est l'idée de la des festivals de
danse donc rendez-vous à ou dans les 5
et 6 mars et je veux propose maintenant
d'aller un tout petit peu plus au sud du
département dans la vallée de chevreuse
à choisel pour rencontrer le marquis de
breteuil et savoir ce qui se passe au
château de breteuil et bien pour toutes
les vacances scolaires il ya toujours
des événements particuliers et pour
cette année pour février d'abord le
château est ouvert matin et après midi
sans interruption il est ouvert tous les
jours mais en plus on rajoute des
visites le matin et puis notre thème
général ce sont les contes de perrault
et il y à des nouveautés en ce qui
concerne les comptes
d'abord c'est que la conteuse sera là
tous les jours au lieu de devenir que le
dimanche à 16h30 pour raconter trois
histoires de charles perrault aux
enfants et aux parents
et puis je crois que il ya quelque chose
de particulier vous rendez un hommage à
michel tournier qui a vécu très près
d'ici qu'elle est quelles sont
exactement les actions vous menez pour
pour cet hommage et bien michel tournier
était notre voisin il habitait le
presbytère de choisel de mon village
c'était un homme merveilleux pour moi
c'est le
plus grands écrivains français de la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle et nous
lui rendons hommage parce que michel
tournier a écrit des contes et il
adorait d'ailleurs ses comptes et les
comptes en général il est où nous avons
deux compte que l'on évoque ici d'abord
en permanence pierrot les secrets de la
nuit dans les communs un très joli conte
et puis un autre compte qui sera
racontée tous les jours en même temps
que des contes de perrault par nos
conteuse à 16h30
et ce conte s'appelle la légende du pain
dans puis celle tournée sera présent
deux fois mais bien sûr toujours avec
perreault qui est l'élément fondamental
de l'animation du château nous allons
faire maintenant un voyage dans le temps
et plus particulièrement au moyen âge ça
se passe à trappes et c'est l'histoire
des sceaux du moyen-âge donc il suffira
de vous rendre à trappes pour apprendre
tout sur les sauts des chevaliers et des
seigneurs et comment il les utilisait
pour s'identifier
vous en apprendrez la confection et
l'utilisation de l'époque mais aussi
vous pourrez le fabriquer pour vous même
à l'aide d'un moulage et vous aurez
votre propre saut avec lequel vous
retournerez à la maison un petit
souvenir du moyen-âge en vacances est
toujours sympa rendez-vous à trappes
pour connaître tout sur les sauts nous
allons partir à louveciennes au musée
promenade pour des vacances au musée et
là nous allons allier à la fois les
pratiques musicales tout ce qui est
pratique corporelle et ateliers
artistiques pour quoi faire
et bien pour associer deux comtés
mélanger un peu les personnages des deux
comptes qui sont la belle au bois
dormant et le chat botté et on va faire
avec tout ça un nouveau compte qu'on
aura recréer mais nous allons avoir
aussi la possibilité de faire un film
est un film avec le tous les sons de
walt disney que l'on va créer
m et qui sera tout à fait notre oeuvre
qui pourrait être produite ensuite donc
pour tout ce qui est création
n'oubliez surtout pas il faut absolument
aller aux vacances au musée haut musée
promenade de luz yens savez vous qu'il y
a beaucoup de 2 meur d'artistes dans les
yvelines
et oui c'est le cas de la maison elsa
triolet et aragon et nous aurons
l'occasion pendant les vacances
scolaires d'imaginer sur place un hiver
russe qu'est ce qu'on fera pour
découvrir cet hiver russe eh bien ça
sera l'occasion de créer un livre en
relief avec des poupées russes qu'on
appelle aussi des matriochkas et puis
chaque enfant pourra donner sa version
de l'hiver russe avec des pliages
décollage et des coloriages donc
l'occasion de participer à des ateliers
créatifs dans le dans le creuset de la
création des yvelines maison elsa
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et ce sera les
24 février et les 2 mars
quoi de plus ludique pour occuper les
vacances que d'aller voir un spectacle
de cirque et nous irons donc au 15e
festival international du cirque qui
aura lieu aux mureaux les 5 et 6 mars
prochains
vous découvrirez un tas de spectacles
internationaux
il y aura des jongleurs devant lesquels
vous serez en admiration car les
prouesses sont extraordinaires il y aura
tout un tas de facéties des clowns pour
les enfants et puis les acrobates qui
vous feront frémir par leur talent et
leur virtuosité
n'hésitez pas à aller au festival du
cirque
d'autant que le 6 mars le deuxième jour
du festival
on remettra le prix du meilleur
spectacle
sylvie léonard vous parlez de
l'exposition voyage à travers et les
sauts du moyen-âge présenté par mémoire
de trappes jusqu'au 9 mars prochain une
exposition pour illustrer les recherches
de mémoire de trappes suite à la
découverte du sceau de guillaume de
trappes aujourd'hui conservés aux
archives nationales
vous en dit plus l'existence d'un sceau
officiel celui de guillaume de trappes
ancien chevalier du xiiie siècle
chanoine de la cathédrale d'orléans a
été retrouvé à l'occasion des recherches
menées par mémoire de trappes ce service
public dédié à l'histoire d'un
territoire en perpétuelle mutation
illustre ses recherches par l'exposition
voyage à travers les sauts du moyen-âge
du 12e au 15e siècle présentée jusqu'au
9 mars
cette expo donc reprend la fabrication
l'utilisation les âges des sceaux avec
des visuels et et des explications très
claires et simples les ça explique aussi
également les grandes familles de la
région la ville de trappes était à
l'époque on l'a trouvé ce nom de trappes
xtr aps et était en fête
reconnu comme gîte royal donc une place
forte qui était entretenue pour que les
monarques viennent puissent
lors de leur voyage dans la région
puissent s'arrêter et trouver le confort
et le gîte
cette exposition présente une collection
de moulage des sauts des seigneurs et
chevaliers des yvelines utilisés
autrefois comme signature pour certifier
un acte le saut qui a connu son âge d'or
au 13ème et 14ème siècle renseigne sur
la vie diplomatique et quotidienne du
moyen-âge le sort fait c'est l'empreinte
sur une surface malléable donc à
l'époque c'était la sienne à partir des
matrices qui peut être fabriqué soient
en métal soit en hausse son niveau on va
la retrouver sous plusieurs formes
durant toutes ces années et qui
servirent aux fêtes a signé et on a posé
donc sa signature sur un document de
plus ou moins grande importance pour
mieux comprendre la fabrication des
sauts des ateliers de moulage sont
proposées dans le cadre de l'atelier
ville et des livres et jeux sont
disponibles pour les enfants
un peu de littérature maintenant je vous
propose la sélection du pavé du canal
pauline amis nous présente sa majesté
maman pour la chronique envies de
lecture donc le nouveau roman d'anne
bereg de sa majesté maman c'est un livre
hommage à sa maman elle a toujours écrit
sur sa famille dans tous ses autres
romans mais là c'est vraiment un livre
pour sa mère au moment où elle est
hospitalisée
donc on sait dès le départ que sa maman
va mourir mais c'est absolument pas dans
le pathos c'est plutôt un livre tendre
où elle raconte cette relation mère
fille qui a pas toujours été facile
c'était pas une maman forcément tendre
mais voilà elle se plie en quatre pour
ses enfants elle essaie de leur faire un
festin avec deux trois aliments qui
traînait dans le frigo
elle les a éduqués à la lecture etc
donc elle raconte cette relation il ya
des moments où elle raconte ses
souvenirs avec sa mère et puis des
moments d'échangés entre sa mère et elle
l hôpital elle dénonce aussi les
systèmes de santé en norvège qui n'a
rien à envier à des systèmes de santé de
pied de pays du tiers monde c'est
vraiment très violent voilà c'est un
très beau livre s'étendre c'est drôle
c'est touchant mais c'est absolument pas
triste malgré le sujet et une
information à noter dans vos agendas
pour la première fois dans les yvelines
l'association départementale 78 organise
un grand concert au profit des restos du
coeur le samedi 12 mars au théâtre de
poissy à 20h30 soit 110 choristes et
cinq musiciens aguerris des concerts qui
ont déjà participé trois fois au
festival international de gospel de
paris la recette sera intégralement
reversée aux restos du coeur des
yvelines ceux ci espèrent récolter dix
mille euros soit l'équivalent de dix
mille repas et avant de se quitter
quelques idées sorties pour votre week
end
ce soir vendredi 19 février à 20h30 à la
merise de trappes yom clarinettiste
virtuose nous livre une traversée épique
nautique d'un ailleurs mystique à la
croisée des musiques orientales et
moyen-orientales avec son spectacle le
silence de l'exode
extraits
et demain samedi 20 février à 15 heures
à l'espace albert camus de maurepas
venez assister au spectacle rose de la
compagnie du mouton carré rose est une
petite fille intelligente avec un énorme
défaut de langage mais avec un
formidable appelons rose remet en
question les règles et les conventions
très vite elle réussit à faire de sa
différence une force tu sais rose je
pense que tu es beaucoup plus
intelligente que tu ne le laisse
paraître
non parce que j'ai l'air d'une partie
non non non pas du tout enfin je voulais
dire enfin non ce n'est pas ce que je
voulais dire je pense que le mieux pour
l'exposer ce serait que je commence et
que je finisse vu que c'est moi qui
parle le mieux
et c'est la fin de ce sept huit
week-ends émission à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous souhaite un
excellent week end